good evening to all
welcome to participants and guests who
are with us for the is drawing dead
symposium the formal sessions of which
begin tomorrow afternoon at 2 o'clock
professor Scolari's talk is not only
occasioned by the opening of the
exhibition of his work but also by the
symposium convened by Victor Agron and
George Knight both critics in our school
symposium will begin tomorrow - it will
be followed at 6:30 with Peter cooks a
keynote address and I urge you to get
here early as you will know there are
many people who are not seated in the
auditorium right now but hearing it on
remote and his talk will be real is only
halfway there then the symposium will
continue on Saturday morning beginning
at 9:30 and concluding at the end of the
afternoon around 4:00 with Mario Carr
post concluding talk and a reception
tonight's lecture massimo scolari is
davenport visiting professor the
davenport professorship oldest of the
schools and out visiting professorships
was established through the request of
professor sheppard stevens as a memorial
to his uncle and aunt William B and
Charlotte Shepherd Davenport in 1966
James Stirling was the first davenport
professor serving in that capacity every
full term until 1984 Robert venturi the
second davenport professor occupied the
chair in spring terms from 1966 seven to
1970 since that time very many of the
world's most important architects have
come to Yale as davenport professors
beginning in fall 2003 Greg Lynn has
been davenport professor for one term
each year and professor Scolari joined
our school's faculty is davenport
professor in 2006 professor Scolari's
lecture this evening helps us celebrate
the opening of the exhibition massimo
Scolari
representation of architecture which
will be on display in our schools
gallery until May 4th the exhibit is
curated by Professor scolari work
closely with Laura Silva Streamy as well
as Bryan Butterfield our school's
director of exhibitions I would like to
thank them for their wonderful work in
this cat in this capacity and also to
thank gallery red registrar Linda that
Revere
and the very many work with Brian
Butterfield to ensure the high quality
of this and our other gallery
installations including Alison Walsh
exhibition curator coordinator the work
on display is interpreted in the superb
catalogue essay by Dan Shira Lecter in
history and theory in our school
following its run at Yale the exhibition
is expected to travel beginning in
September it will be at the author J
Houghton jr. gallery of the Cooper Union
and Dean viddler of the Cooper Union is
here with us tonight we welcome him I
would like to extend my particular
appreciation at least Jaffe and Jeffrey
Brown for the support of the scolari
exhibition as well as to the Turner
foundation whose special support made
possible the construction and
installation of the glider wing that has
elegantly suspended above the gallery
for this show Massimo Scolari is a
powerful force in architecture and
culture operating at the intersection of
history Theory polemics drawing and
design after graduating from the Milan
Polytechnic in 1969 professor scolari
joined the editorial staff of contra
spazio a remarkable magazine then edited
by Pol Pot Agassi at the same time he
assisted his former teacher aldo rossi
both at the milan polytechnic and in
Rossi's architectural studio in 1973 mr
Scolari took a post of the university of
Palermo teaching history and
architecture and at the University of
Venice where he taught techniques and
history of drawing positions he held
until his decision to
sign in 2000 in the 1970s and 1980s
Professor Scolari along with Aldo Rossi
Leone career Paulo Portuguese you know a
mongrel among others revolutionized this
course and formal structure of modern
architecture his pavilion on the Strada
Nova Simha of the first Venice Biennale
in nineteen our architecture Biennale in
1980 was one of the definitive talismans
of the newly emerged post-modernism
throughout this period and to the
present massimo scolari has continued to
work as an editor on architectural
journals such as contra spazio Lotus and
Casabella
and on the literary journal IKOS while
creating drawings and innovative
installations for the Venice Biennale in
1980 84 1991 1996 and 2004 in 2000
Massimo gained his private pilot's
license which may go a long way to
explaining the sculptured airplane that
floats above our gallery and in so many
of his drawings
I want to thank personally Massimo
Scolari for his friendship to me and to
the school and for the great spirit of
collaboration and support he has
afforded all of us involved in making
this exhibit and this symposium possible
following this evening's lecture
professor scolari will be available
during the reception in the gallery to
sign copies of his just published book
massimo scolari
the representation of architecture
published this year by Skara in an
english-language version and a bit which
is a beautifully crafted and beautifully
illustrated collection of his essays now
please join me in welcoming Massimo
scolari Davenport professor back to Yale
his topic is representations Massimo
good evening ladies and gentlemen and
colleagues it is a special exciting for
me to be here this evening because the
school want to honneur my work with our
at respective exhibition I would like to
thank especially Robert Stern who has
made it always possible with great
generosity and friendship and allowed me
also to design the exhibition and to be
the curator of the exhibition I would
like to thank also Peter asthma for in
stimulating criticism that has continued
to nurture our 40-year friendship and
all those who helped to put together the
exhibition and this event Oscar Wilde
once said artists are of two kinds some
of answers and others questions it is
important to know which group as an
artist you belong to since the one who
questions is never the one who gives the
answers there are works that remain
misunderstood for a long time but look
for answers to question not yet asked
since often question arises long after
the answer I don't know which category I
belong to but the exhibition the school
has honored my work with leads me to
believe my answer I've finally gotten
there question is the drawing dead back
in 1974 on December 31st it was in
London
at a New Year's Eve party a bit aloof as
usually I saw someone who seems even
Shire and more self-conscious with me
it was the Italo Calvino a common friend
introduced me as a young professor of
architecture but Calvino's face lit up
only when he heard I was also a painter
Calvino was 51 and already a celebrity I
was 20 years younger and totally unknown
as we waited for midnight the
conversation with Calvino flow
gracefully among compliments while I
kept thinking what a godsend it was
meeting him and the invisible City his
novel published in 1972 would somehow be
the subject of my painting suddenly an
angel passed the rooms noise subdued and
I found myself saying much too loudly
Calvino I will really like to illustrate
invisible City with my watercolors
Calvino bleens loli toward me and in a
low tone said that the description of
those 55 invisible cities where to
incomplete to be representin a sixteenth
way by a painter moreover he asked me
with a friendly smile like this one
how could I ever be able to portray the
city of them road where quotation the
mood of the beholder gives the city of
them root its form inhibited by his
kindness I nevertheless point out if it
weren't the images Marco Polo drew in
the air precisely the most bet recurring
Kublai Khan mind wearing most figures
drawing the air
representable in all their 55
combination that's true Calvino said but
he said memories images one fix in words
are arranged as Marco Polo said also
about Venice dissolving in the
description of all of our cities maybe
some city could be omitted I suggest
shyly and that that precise moment the
clock struck midnight for me a new story
had begun though only now I have been
able to piece it back together
thanks to this talk
I began to ask myself if it was really
impossible going backwards to retrace
the faint unfolding of those printed
letters in order to see if the images
but writing as had erased
RIA Marg all illustrators have come
across with difficulty but here
among other reason the very title
invisible City made it a absolute
Calvino's writing which seemed at the
first moment very simple is scattered
with clever logical omission and
non-return valves that provoke a
compression and a subsequent expansion
in meaning the story flows oscillating
between the prodigious possibility the
differences offered and the concrete
number of the city visited by Marco Polo
but that logical incompleteness obliges
the reader to constantly look back
towards the lost meaning while the flow
of the story pushes him forward along
with Marco Polo's narration an exemplary
case is found in the description of the
city of Zoar Zoe where Marco Polo seems
to outline with simplicity the city
archetype each man bears
in his mind a city made only of
differences a city without figures and
form and individual cities fill it up
that definition remind me of the logical
of that infinite sphere whose the center
is everywhere but whose circumference is
nowhere a figure that never reach its
border
but cross the sparkling constellation of
archetypes scattered across the entire
earth by man from the Tower of Babel to
the Noah's Ark and even the Pyramid of
Egypt archetypes
that spoke to me of a remote and primary
genial and acuity of that beauty which
worlds of heaven of laconic form that
profoundly touch my imagination like
earth mound but reveal to a dove loss
the very idea of architecture firm
rooted in mythical space like primordial
types and pedo clay describes in his
physical poem where he writes of the
birth of man quote in the beginning
shapeless typos emerged from her
Calvino's american lesson published
after his death highlighted his idea of
precision that was a well calculated
drawing incisive and vivid the images a
precise language both in it lexicon and
neons
precisely as Aristotle recommended
describe a painting at the beginning of
the speech to give the discourse the
vividness of image that was called in
Greek inner Galia a precision in
accordance also with the philosophy of
the composition by the Edgar Allan Poe
we're definitely distance me from all
random and foggy idea of inspiration
pour that literary plan the 108 verses
of the Raven with the bravery of poetry
the precision the term meaning its
sphere of action the tone and dramatic
use of repetition with the Nevermore
Nevermore Nevermore refrain
but Calvino's precision lay not only in
the feature of the composition like
lightness visibility of sweetness
gently channel through the fluidity of
his style
there was a poetic pressure that allowed
him to create all the surreal effects
for his iridescent list of cities cities
that were certainly very far from the
pole the political circumstances of the
time because they express an autonomy of
art which kept distancing itself from
that very reality this fantastical
aspect unpopular with the left-wing
accrete ex was precisely what made
invisible city a powerful magnet but
will detach me from the historical city
I had dedicated years of research we
found arose that evening in London there
certainly was a promise in the air
in any event at the moment of the
surrender the angel left me a gift
the idea of incompleteness in 1986 the
idea would become the moving force
behind my collector room at the Milano
is the project of I did with Aldo Rossi
during the course and competition of
scandia
but in 1986 the idea of incompleteness
become the center the moving force of
behind my collector room in the Milan
adrenaline Noah's Ark the archetype of
collecting that had its center Ignis the
god of oblivion he prevents the
completion of
whole collection for someone like myself
who wasn't drone to the building
profession Calvino's text promised and
interpretation of an underground and
mysterious city where as in Burgas
magical library of Babel a
self-contained universe was described a
universe I would not share with any
triumphant I ideology or even compare
with the urban analogy gaining ground
among Aldo Rossi disciples in complete
length was certainly not the defect 12
century Chinese manuals criticized to
painter who drew streams without Springs
trees with less than three branches or
stone with only one side it wasn't
something lacking but a poetic tension
pointed towards the enigma just as the
Sphinx giving complete and obscure
answer to life and art questions
incompleteness paved the way for me to
study enigma that suspension between
sound and meaning that constitute the
very sense of poetry for poor Valerie
which has nothing to do with the lack of
mellows in contemporary classic music or
with the absence of meaning in the
pronouncement of artists hours through
the practice of art alone I have arrived
at the fully grasp this principle which
in music is expressed in imperfect and
deceptive cadenza but is postponing
conclusion by shifting to a different
analogy or keeping the form suspended
awaiting an amp ready
de Vil outcome actually it seemed that
this way of never finishing never ending
could become a logical and compositional
principle where beauty came about
through omission beauty as omission from
that encounter I learn how each work
must remain incomplete and posed on
differences to keep question about its
essence alive and its ultimate aim
enigmatic because multiform
interpretation which bound a work of art
to the intelligible world only can flow
through the gaps of incompleteness
stupidity said flow Barre lies in
wanting to draw conclusions today
precision and incompleteness seems to be
at odds with digital design employed by
everyone in school and on the job now
I'd like to dwell on this for a moment
all of Calvino's indication regarding
precision seems to fall upon the
characteristic of digital drawing
especially in the celebrated texts of
his American lesson he said precision
means free things are well defined and
well calculated drawing on the work
evoke in vivid incisive and memorable
visual images a language as precise as
possible in vocabulary and in rendering
neurons of thought and imagination of
course but in design process the
imprecision of the sketch and the
digital precision are not in
contradiction it is a matter of two
distinct but complementary mental set
Rambla cast in opposition to graphic
expression which are in any event
secondary after the clarity of the
mental image but each architect should
have a well-defined before touching a
computer or a pencil this initial phase
the mind's drawing loves the slow pace
and the silence of the reflection and
unfolding dialogue which memory since
nothing come from nothing and if
something come from nothing it can as
quickly disappear into nothingness with
a click of the mouse this first phase
remains inaccessible to the tentacle of
the computer just like the second phase
the sketches which in a certain sense
third sense is a sort of mystical gulf
where doubt dilute and the most distant
sonorities are modulated the software
may transform a freehand sketch into a
measure drawing does not understand the
quality of thought but by its very
nature is innumerable and whose
precision and definition are hard
achievement not standard operating
condition the precision of electronic
drawing would seems to follow the
recommendation of Calvino
but the impossibility of circumscribing
the infinite and equivalent computer
combination absurdly makes necessary
imprecision a condition of creativity
and style since in drawing style depends
less on our ability then on our limits
and emissions and Calvino third point
that is rendering the neurons of thought
and imagination
is an objective difficult to obtain with
a computer no machine as sophisticated
as it may be has ever been able to
replicate the density of events of
personal experience rent atlas relented
less dynamic of our mind just as our
handwriting reveals our personality to a
graphologist a sketch Auto graphically
portrays what we think and single us out
with confidence we are our self in the
auto graphic drawing and our culture is
reflected there instead the keyboard
immerses us in the machine by channeling
our imagination and obliges us to lose
the critical distance that is always
established in the hand drawing
splitting the event we create from the
incessant and unpredictable intervention
of memory the computer user suffers a
saturation of aesthetic images the
driving toward a sort of paralysis
similar to the standard syndrome or even
toward the ease of photographical
composition orthogonal composition
except of course for the primary project
the precision of a computer's
indiscriminate memory immobilize our
selective memory by encrypting it in a
cloud or cooling it on a server by the
North Pole a computer the localizer our
memory because the entire information
library doesn't belong to us because it
is not inside us it has a little to do
with our feelings and our mind that is
with our memory
the problem is we need both
even if an operation with CAD requires
more attention when a freehand drawing
it is clear but the computer allows what
our and do not instantaneously passing
from an infinitesimal to a very large
scale without losing the same
information but but we know that higher
detail definition entails a progressive
increase in the drawings scale and
measurement precision a procedure but
the computer dislikes but I would like
to leave this problem to the drawing
symposium and quickly get back to my
meeting with Calvino and his unexpected
consequences at the end of 1970s I
decided to ask Paulo for sáááty then
publishing director of an Audi to give
his friend Calvino the slide of my
watercolors Calvino answer in a
surprising way he said that I should not
illustrate his invisible cities but
instead he would like to describe my
visible cities with that replay
Calvino has established a gap that could
not be filled between representing and
describing between linguistic expression
and figurative experience between the
elusiveness of visual imagination is
city refer osto and the overflowing
wealth of the pictorial representation
with a young man's typical stubbornness
in 1977 I began to draw the invisible
City but a few years later on September
nineteen Calvino suddenly pass away and
with him when the OPA favored reading
was promised descriptions but when
something is taken away something else
takes its place I never would have
imagined that 30 years later that nearly
the Giudice is best intellectual a would
have written about was very images the
most beautiful and touching words critic
have ever dedicated to my work evidence
of that encounter
remain in my drawing and after almost 40
years I realized how in depth that I am
to Calvino and how many element of his
poetics have silently materialized in my
watercolors recently I found a notebook
with drawing better refer to bat
encounter on the right is a page where I
was starting to draw some indication
actually very little and very difficult
to be kept Calvino's word resurface
transforming my appetite oral desire
into memories and offering my
imagination that theater of memory in
which I could experiment with the
infinite combination of the laconic
element but I had started to draw in
1975 for my Cornell University student
this one is the gas station in on the on
the Left I draw for the student and that
is where this form come from is a German
book on a play for little girls and men
that was the same element coming from
the invisible City illustration of
Calvino become then illustration for my
1977 design program at the Cooper Union
at the time of John Hay Duke Slutsky and
Raymond Abrams and the Peter iseman
publishers after worlds in 1978 this
kind of object which has been now
realized with a computer system in the
exhibition
the unfolding of Calvino stories flows
in the same manner or as my research
almost like a parallel reality in fact
in the beginning markup always presses
himself with gesture because it doesn't
know the the language of the emperor and
he represents the city showing how big
they were which kind of items they were
gathered there then he learns the
language and his story always seems to
revolve around the same element always
the same and come back in differences he
describes city where quotation you could
wander through them in thought become
lost stop and enjoy the cool air or run
off then the cupola can realize that
Marco Polo's city are resembled one
another and impose a change and he said
from now on I shall describe the cities
and you will go around and tell me if
they exist this change in strategy on
the part of Kublai Khan led to an equal
radical change in my artistic research
refusing to practice as an architect in
the late 1970s nevertheless some of my
representation went in search of
realization it was a long journey of
painted images toward the built world
web began began with gas station in and
was followed by the painted gate for a
maritime City along with long backward
journey some forms represented came to
have measurement and enter the material
world like this one for the Biennale in
1980 Stratton of Aseema at the first
international potential as a visual
organized by Paulo Fortaleza
at the Venice pier
in 1980 the asana metric abstraction of
gate for a maritime city was included on
most by chance eluding postmodern of
censorship I did not feature historical
references or parodies or even flashy
inflated columns it was a simply simply
an axonometric representation with that
jump off the painting and at the last
time the same happened afterwards with
an installation called behind the sky
but born from a painting and then the
theme of the wings this is an
interesting image because an
aeronautical engineer a certain point
said to me you are just painting all
this kind of machine flying but they
cannot fly and so he was challenging me
and we start to build together the best
kind of glider you see underneath and it
was perfectly flying actually and so he
was deceived about this situation and
then happened with in the Biennale of
1991 the glider became a construction
which was a heavy glider it was about 40
tons and then became the symbol of the
School of Architecture in Venice and
then of course another theme of my
research which was the column and the
broken column became the theme of a new
Biennale which was run by court foster
metamorph in fact I took one wing
the rotation of the wing I put inside
the staircase and that was the
demonstration of the this kind of the
constructive situation that can be
easily be reconstructed you see you know
the the staircase was in one part
looking as a turbine and the other one
was a simple staircase very exactly
similar to the Pilate one in the convent
of la garita going back to Calvino's
story for Kublai Khan the understandable
fist Empire is reduced to an infinite
combination of chess game at the
checkmate beneath the foot of the king
knocked aside aside by the winners and
nothingness remain a black square or a
white one he understands that victory is
reduced to a square of painted wood
nothingness once again Calvino overturns
the game with an admirable Adagio on
Marco Polo's part but he start to
demonstrate to the Emperor but this
nothingness is a kind of very rich world
and he said here is a thicker poor
perhaps perhaps it was a larvas
nest not a wood wall would work because
once born it would ever began to dig but
a caterpillar that note the leaves and
was the cause of the trees being chosen
for chopping down the nothingness of a
spot or a scribble that nature left in
the square contained an entire universe
just as imperfection on a blank sheet is
the place around which imagination
slowly creates the pearl of the
represented
Calvino's chess game is certainly a
metaphor for the entire but also for
life since young people do not live as
as chess player as a prima Livy said
that is to say meditating before every
move though knowing that the time
allotted for each move is limited
remembering that each move provokes
another one on the part of the adversary
difficult but not impossible to foresee
and paying for the wrong moves but they
are always here reversible chess player
are a bit like tennis player or poet
they are irritated easily with ease
because they are totally responsible for
the actions and they cannot blame others
they have no excuses and excuse are a
precious painkiller thus I would like
invite student to become chess players
to think twice before moving upon the
chess board of the project and to avoid
using the excuse painkiller to match but
also to understand that when all seems
lost and under the Vanquish king they
remain nothing but an insignificant
wooden square main reality reveal the
story of an infinite life and natural
reaching a simplicity that lies at the
base of every grained work where the
Oracle of Delphi invitation resound no
they self or
become what you are as Nietzsche said
thank you for your attention